there's some advice that's gone viral on
Tick Tock this of course is the advice
that white people
who go to see black panther or the New
Black Panther movie on opening weekend
are in fact anti-black
[Music]
this message is to all our would-be
accomplices and white allies this
message is to all the white people who
have BLM in their bio
want to prove to black people that you
love us and you care about us and you
are down for the cause do not go see
that movie opening weekend
you buy your ticket you give it to a
black person or a black family who can't
afford to go and then you go sit at that
theater in front of the doors you make
sure that every black person in that
theater can enjoy that movie in peace
you make sure that you use your body to
block us from anybody who would be
coming in that theater to do us harm
that is your job
you can go see it on another weekend go
see it on the second or third weekend
but the first weekend that's for us to
do anything other than this is
anti-black
so you got to give her credit for a good
grift for a good con it's worked on a
lot of people uh this is what all of the
anti-racism stuff is about it's just a
it's just a power move it's just a con
to say hey give me something hey you
shut up you shut up let me do whatever I
want and that's that's the effect give
me money give me whatever that's all it
is it's a really cynical Shakedown kind
of thing as she is expressing but hey if
the Khan's working for her I guess uh
you know there's there's some cleverness
involved on this one in particular
though I have to say
fine by me she can have my ticket to the
New Black Panther movie that black
panther was so bad I had to watch it
because daily wire made me because I had
to give a review it was so terrible I
didn't enjoy a single second of it it's
not a good movie and I assume since
sequels are generally not as good as the
first I assume black panther 2 is going
to be even worse so yes
call I am the new ibram Candy
I am basically Robin D'Angelo here you
may lady you may have my ticket to Black
Panther
I don't have a ticket I don't have one
yet but if I find one you can have it
the Democrats are looking ahead
and not not only I mean I assume they're
doing their absolute best to salvage
this election but they're looking ahead
they're saying man this is going so
poorly for us that we've already got to
deny the 2024 election
what are you actually suggesting we do
if Trump wins fair and square let's
forget about any like Foul Play or
anything like that if he wins in 2024
what are you going to do are you going
to respect somebody
I mean I don't accept the premise of
your question if he wins in 2024 let's
forget the foul play how can I forget
the foul play when right now if the
Republicans
voting rules Charlie right now they are
taking steps to make sure that the 2024
election is not a free
elections
to accept that outcome then that's
concerning to me I'm not hold on I'm I'm
willing to accept an outcome of a free
and fair election shady as of right now
do you believe the 2024 election will be
a free and fair election if black people
are denied the right to vote if there is
racist
black people have been the vote has been
taken away from them
this is exaggerating rhetoric
there you have it there you have it
and this shouldn't be surprising to
people who
who understand the leftist point of view
when the left uses the word democracy
they don't really mean democracy
obviously not because they say that
Donald that the people voting for Donald
Trump is a threat to democracy the
people the Italians voting for Georgia
Maloney is a threat to democracy the
hungarians voting for Victor rabban is a
threat to democracy the people electing
someone
by definition is an expression of
democracy
so obviously democracy doesn't mean what
they seem to think it means for the the
left democracy just means liberalism
and and so
the people have to vote for liberalism
they have to liberalism
necessarily according to the libs has to
Triumph at The Ballot Box in order for
it to be a legitimate election
it's not just that sometimes the
Republicans steal the elections or
sometimes the Democrats deal the
elections it's according to the libs
every election that the Democrats win
even if they steal it is legitimate and
every election that the Republicans win
even if it is completely above board you
can't point to a single problem with it
every single election has to be
illegitimate because liberalism and
democracy to them are the exact same
thing
and because the only reason because
liberalism is so manifestly good and
true and in everyone's interests the
only reason that you could not vote for
the liberal is because you were not
permitted to through suppression or you
were misinformed you were deceived it
was a fraud
it's this ignorance it's a false
consciousness you're laying laboring
under but either way it has to be
illegitimate
now it's ironic of course because we've
heard for two years now that the
greatest threat to our democracy is
denying elections they're already
denying the next one of course they will
and what I've been trying to tell people
from the very beginning especially since
we've heard all this hullabaloo BS about
January 6th then the January 6 committee
and the greatest threat to our country
is to deny our sacred democracy the
liberals do not give a damn about the
Democracy they they openly deride the
Democracy when the Democracy elects
people that they don't like stop taking
it seriously stop taking the bait now I
think
uh finally people are getting that
argument because you're seeing that
reflected in the polls the Democrats
went all in it's just amazing they went
all in this year on really two issues
they said the two issues that Americans
care about are
abortion
and January 6th 2021 this this sort of
unruly event at the Capitol that's it
and by the way I care a lot about
abortion I'm very pro-life very very
strongly pro-life
very few people care about abortion on
the pro-life side or the pro-life
approach Choice side when when they're
actually casting their vet
it matters as a top issue to something
like 15 of people
and then on January say no nobody cares
like truly a negative people care cares
about January 6th
so there are they're already trying
to deny it
but of course it is not
illegitimate for the people to reject
liberalism in fact I think the people
should always reject liberalism I think
liberalism is just wrong and bad in all
of its forms it's it should be cast
aside we don't it's not good
and people have good reason to reject
the the liberalism and the terrible
liberal candidates now we get to
the much more philosophically
satisfying part of the show
and oh I'm sorry physically satisfying
part of the show uh that is when I kill
Jake crane that's right he lost the
fantasy football game I won it now he
has to eat a poison chip while I watch
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]